how's it going citizens of the reject
nation it is jon back here once again
for a solo movie reaction and today i'm
very excited because we are going uh
back into my childhood or at least the
childhood i might have had had i not
missed this movie completely growing up
and it's funny because there are a few
disney movies from around this period of
time that for whatever reason i just
didn't wind up seeing it wasn't what i
was asking my family to take me to and
it wasn't what they were going to just
on their own so yeah we're filling in
some of the blanks and i'm very excited
today to be checking out the emperor's
new groove i've been hearing people talk
about this movie for years i know people
love it i am excited to check it out
myself i only know
what i remember about the trailer
growing up so this is going to be a
totally fresh experience so if you would
be so kind please leave a like on this
video leave me your thoughts on the
movie on anything you want to point out
or enlighten me to and don't forget to
hit that subscribe button along with the
notification bell so you can be notified
any and every time something of interest
to you drops on the channel and of
course if you'd like to join me for the
complete experience of the emperor's new
groove come on over to our patreon page
patreon.com the real rejects we're over
there you can sync up with the time code
bring your own copy watch the full movie
alongside me as well we have a whole
bunch of other shows and movies that
have exclusive reaction highlights and
watchalongs included it's a lot of fun
over there and uh yeah if you like this
hat check out our
shopzeroaddition.com store and a big old
thank you to the prepa team for dicing
up these highlights and without further
ado
let's have ourselves at disney day
[Music]
well you'll never believe this but that
llama you're looking at was once a human
being
and not just any human being that guy
was an emperor
a rich powerful ball of charisma oh yeah
he must have done something man i'm that
llama
the name is kuzco
i was the world's nicest guy and they
ruined my life for no reason
i'm sure i'm sure
[Music]
whoa
we got some tom jones right now
no one has ever
actually has a pretty funny gang
with the kiss stamp
[Music]
no
you threw off my groove i'm sorry no
thrown off the emperor's groove
no oh
geez
elder abuse
yes
river dance jokes
i remember when river dance jokes were
very topical let me show you the people
responsible for ruining my life
first
there's pacha
now excuse me i'm here to see emperor
kuzco you see i got the summon inside up
the stairs that's definitely a john
goodman
oh
uh
pardon me that's mine oh here you go
thank you you're welcome
[Laughter]
what happened well i
i threw off the emperor's groove what is
groove the rhythm in which he lives his
life his pattern of behavior i threw it
off and the emperor had me thrown out
the window oh
dear
this is isma the emperor's advisor
living proof that
now lately esma's gotten into this bad
habit of trying to run the country
behind my back
and i'm thinking that's gotta stop it is
no concern of mine whether your family
has what was it again um food
i'm the emperor and you're the emperor's
advisor remember that but your highness
i was only dealing with meaningless
peasant matters wow
look at these wrinkles
what is holding this woman together
this internal monologue is
quite rye thank you whoa no touchy no
touching the village leader is here to
see oh great send them in yeah people
did the no touchy things so much when
this came out i remember that you mean
fired um how else can i say it you're
being let go your department is being
downsized you're part of an out
placement we're going in a different
direction we're not picking up your
options oh
i do love like animated movie grumbling
just like miscellaneous
my village oh yeah you got a pretty
sweet little set up there on top of that
hill don't you
yeah my family has lived on that hilltop
for the last six generations
aha uh oh
oh no when the sun hits that ridge just
right
these hills sing
well that settles it the hills are alive
i just needed an insider's opinion
before i okayed this spot for my pool
uh
your pool
welcome to
my ultimate summer getaway complete with
waterslide
how could he do this to me why i
practically raised him
with him out of the way and no heir to
the throne i'll take over and rule the
empire
brilliant to the secret lab
pull the level
[Music]
ah
how should i do it i am
it's a really punchy movie
you know
oh right the poison the poison for
couscous the poison chosen specially to
kill cusco cuz goes poison
fat poison
few drops in his drink then i'll propose
a toast and he will be dead before
dessert dead by dawn
they're still hot
[Music]
a toast to the emperor
long live cusco
oh
so what are you gonna do i mean you've
been around here a long time and
i really mean a long time
um
i mean it might
be difficult for someone of your age
adjusting to life in the private sector
hey croc private sector
well let's face it you're no spring
chicken
and i mean that the best possible way
what a llama he's supposed to be dead
yeah weird
let me see that vile
[Laughter]
still think i'm not the victim here
watch it gets better
he's doing his own theme music
[Laughter]
i'm enjoying the sort of rye tone
this movie's taken so far
[Music]
oh yep
i'll grow a conscience now buddy
my shoulder angel don't listen to that
guy
he's trying to lead you down the path of
righteousness
rock
that's a harp
and that's a dress robe look what i can
do
but
what does that have to do with him no no
he's got a point
[Laughter]
never heard patrick warburton's voice
chipmunked like that
i selected his devil voice wears hipster
glasses
oh god oh jeez
how about cracking come on here okay
what do i do why do i oh
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
wow
[Music]
it doesn't remind me how much i miss
this animation style
in the main stream
[Music]
like ah how beautiful huh
dad's home
guys
oh dang another one in the world
today oh was mom baking again
don't tell her i said that i heard that
someone's not gonna have a fourth kid
now
keep making cracks like that emperor or
no emperor it's called common courtesy
if that were me i'd march right back
there and demand to see him and you know
i would sweetie sweetie i think you
should excuse me two seconds here um i'm
the one in the car remember
this story's about me not him
okay you got it all right we're gonna
move ahead sorry to slow you down thank
you i appreciate that
of course
where'd
emperor cusco yeah who do you think you
were talking to
my face good my beautiful beautiful face
i know you're horribly ugly now
eastman's got that
secret lab
i'll just snap my fingers and order her
to change me back hey you no time to
waste let's go
i love his his like sea legs
his llama sea legs i can't let you go
back unless you change your mind and
build your summer home somewhere else
growing that spine
i can find my own way back i wouldn't
recommend it it's a little dangerous if
you don't know the way scary jungle
right oh a leaf oh it might attack me
oh it's a scary tree i'm afraid
[Laughter]
please never find my way i'm the emperor
and as such i'm born with an innate
sense of direction
okay where am i
so my favorite animation tropes is the
eyes and the bushes what do you want
oh for me
why i don't know what to say
i mean
that squirrel ever do to you
[Music]
now
[Laughter]
[Music]
love that red background too
very expressive
[Music]
there's a subtle tarzan knot in there
[Music]
don't worry your highness i got you
you're safe now
this this is all right we can figure
this out
that's
about to say that you're secure at least
but now
[Applause]
jeepers
i don't know about you but i'm getting
all funned out
uh-oh
don't tell me we're about to go over a
huge waterfall yep sharp rocks at the
bottom most likely
bring it on
[Laughter]
it's character growth right there
oh
all right
gay panic whatever you call it
llama spit done what i ordered you to do
in the first place we all could have
been spared your little kiss of life
dang he is good at that oh my but now
that you're here you will take me back
to the palace i just think if you really
thought about it you decided to build
your home on a different hilltop and why
would i do that
[Laughter]
you know what someday you're gonna wind
up all alone and you'll have no one to
blame but yourself
thanks for that i'll log that away
i wonder what the sedition laws are like
in this kingdom
because unless you change your mind i'm
not taking you back
[Music]
that we mourn the sudden departure of
our beloved prince
taken from us so tragically on the very
eve of his 18th birthday oh dang his
legacy will live on in our hearts
that's a crazy altar though of those
skull cauldrons he's dead right tell me
cusco's dead i need to hear these words
how do you need to hear all those words
exactly
oh no
if he talks we are thrown now let's
and was careening how to control down a
raging river of death all right all
right
got a mental link or something
i mean there's lots of hilltops and
maybe i might you know you've changed
your mind
because you know that means you're doing
something nice for someone else and
you're all right with that
yes
[Laughter]
don't shake
unless you mean it
oh
all right
let's get you back to the palace
this is the start of a beautiful
friendship
no
thank you
oh no what did you
do what did you do cuzco
okay once we cross this bridge it's only
an hour to the palace good because
believe it or not i think i need a bath
i can't believe it what was that nothing
no
oh no
cuzco
yeah quick help me up
no i don't think i will
wow
i thought you were a changed man oh come
on i had to say something to get you to
take me back to the city so all of it
was a lie well yeah
bye-bye
serves you
serves you right let's end this ladies
first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you knew this was coming pete
oh
teamwork
now we're gonna have to work together to
get out of this so follow my lead ready
right foot who's right you're right or
are mine i don't care
right
left right i was really afraid he was
gonna screw that up
you know it's a good thing you're not a
big fat guy or this would be really
difficult ouch
almost
god
it's stuck
take your time no hurry here
alone oh [ __ ] that is not what i was
expecting
oh there's a nightmare that is such a
nightmare
for a second i was gonna say that's not
as bad but no
that's
probably just as bad
i knew it you know what that there is
some good in you after all i know admit
it wrong
no i'm an evil tyrant
i'm an amoral ruler
talking llama
ah he doesn't really want to talk to you
well then you ask him
hate being in the middle squeaky uh
squeak squeaker quicken
[Laughter]
now ask him which way the talking llama
went ah squeaky squeak squeaking
oh there's an excellent use of patrick
warburton in this movie we'll have two
specials is that all right dear oh
whatever you say pumpkin you know what i
like
we're on our honeymoon
bless you for coming out in public
[Laughter]
hot and crispy pill bug for the happy
couple
hey
somebody else in the world calls him a
pill bug
wowie
oh boy
that's not how i'm used to hanging with
pill bugs
oh here let me get that for you
oh boy
i used to collect them growing up so
now i feel all conflicted in this moment
i'm like friends
i should have gone away with cousco
myself when i had the chance
you really got to stop beating yourself
up about that
[Laughter]
so i'm just checking to make sure you're
gonna take the main course up a notch is
there anything on this menu that is not
swimming in gravy hang on i'll go ask
the chef oh no
hey i didn't ask about dessert yet
hey pal what's your policy on making
special orders all right buster that's
it you want a special order then you
make it i quit don't lie
and i tried
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is he doing in there
come on in a minute i'm still hungry
okay i'll make it simple for you i'll
have a spinach omelette with wheat toast
you got it
[Laughter]
while you're at it make me the special
and hold the gravy
can i order the potatoes as a side fish
i'll have to charge you full price
hey how about a side of potatoes
fuzzy ass cheese no hold the cheese no i
want the cheese cheese it is cheese me
no likey
he's in oh come on make up your mind
okay okay on second thought make my
potatoes
[Music]
that's a very fun bit
[Laughter]
[Music]
no problem hon we do that all the time
what the
what's what you're gonna
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what a birthday is trying to
kill you kill me the whole world
revolves around me no i can't let you
what you want to keep me stranded out
here forever
all you care about is your your stupid
hilltop what you don't care about me now
just get out of here go but that's not a
good argument
what i do that's sombrero though those
poisons cusco would be dead now there'll
be no more diversions until we track
that llama down and kill him said i was
sorry can't just let it go
gotcha
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
spoke too soon buddy
[Music]
oh
no
poncha's poncho
[Music]
the peasant hit the diner
you didn't pass
jack best employee anyone could ask for
whether you're their employer or not
it's the president who i saw leaving the
city who disappeared into the crowd with
cusco in the back of his car
he must have taken him back to his
village so if we find the village we
find him and if we find him we find
guard no
oh the shadows
that's cool
that's a very cool nuance
[Music]
you know call me crazy for following
this guy all the way out here but as
much as he tries to deny it i know
there's some good in him oh
[Laughter]
what i said to you back at the diner
that i i didn't really
oh
so
you're tired of being a llama
yes
yeah we just sent them up to your house
what did they look like well you see
there was this big guy and this older
woman who was a well how would you
describe her scary beyond all reason
of course
you know why don't you just come back
when pacha gets home i'm sure he'd love
to show you the
whoa
excuse me won't you i think i left
something in the oven this is my
variation of double dutch on the signal
we switched place
i have to get back to the palace find
the lab and change him back hi there
what do you mean the door is stuck try
jiggling the handle there is no handle
in here there's not are you sure all
right tell us where the talking lamer is
and we'll burn your house to the ground
ah don't you mean ore
and we'll burn your house to the ground
oh we'll burn your house to the ground
well which isn't great that seems like a
crucial conjunction
i'll break it down myself
oh one okay kids you know what to do
right mom
[Music]
okay children on your mark get set
go oh no
[Music]
oh there wow go
they're getting away
well i had a great time let's not wait
until the next family reunion to get
together
i i hope he remains part of the family
[Music]
oh yeah now now we're going now we're
grooving now we're getting that new
groove
take it for a walk boys
[Music]
of course
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
not bad
that was delightful
okay why does she even have that lover
like dexter's laboratory
over here it has to be one of these
lions tigers bears
oh my
looking for this
beat me to it
no it can't be how did you get back here
before us
uh
how did we cronk well you got me
by all accounts it doesn't make sense
[Laughter]
that's a great way to explain that away
it's called a cruel irony like my
dependence on you i can't believe this
is happening then i bet you weren't
expecting this
[Music]
oh okay
that was
cheeky
uh where's the other guy
no
i'm sorry i'm lying oh what'd i miss
well isma just tossed me this knife and
asked me to you know
you believe it was good
why did i think you could do this this
one simple thing it's like i'm talking
to a monkey oh a really really big
stupid monkey named crack ouch and do
you want to know something else i've
never liked your spinach puffs
no
oh no
she's going
from above the wicked shall receive
their just reward
[Music]
that'll work
that usually works and so does this
[Music]
[Music]
it seems like you would want to label
those
[Music]
they're not listening to me just take
them off
get them hey i've been turned into a cow
can i go home you're excused
anyone else no
we got this
try this one
uh huh little help
[Music]
no
tortusco
[Applause]
oh please be something with wings
yeah
we're flying
oh no
[Music]
we're not getting anywhere with you
picking the vials i'm picking the next
one fine by me give me that one
yep
quick drain the canals
open up
yeah i'm a llama again
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice
that's quite a nostril it's gotta be one
of these
[Music]
no
that this is the one this will change
your back to a human
[Music]
where did it go
no
what ugh
[Music]
no pager
catch it
[Music]
save him
it's a good sequence of shots
play up the suspense
for the last time we did not order a
giant trampoline you know pal you could
have told me that before i set it up
[Applause]
oh yeah
the vial
you think of what i'm thinking
yeah
teamwork
getting the job done
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what are the odds that trap door leading
me out here
i do appreciate this motif of like
randomly convenient things happening
and then just explaining it away with
these like
fourth-wallish comments
you said when the sun hits this ridge
just right these hills sink well pal i
was dragged all over those hills and i
did not hear any singing i'll be
building my summer home on a more
magical hill
thank you
couldn't pull the wall over your eyes
huh
no no i'm sharp i'm on it looks like you
and your family are stuck on the
tuneless hilltop forever pal
hmm
i'm gonna go kick some other peasants
out of their homes
built my summer house
you know
i'm pretty sure i heard some singing on
the hill next to us
in case you're interested oh
neighbors
[Music]
a perfect world will come to be but
everybody here can see that a perfect
world begins and ends
no
did you eat the acorn
squeaking you owe me a new acorn squeak
squeak squeak squeak squeakers
squeaking i'm so proud of you guys
nice
nice nicely done that was very fun
oh
got a very soothing track from sting
this is an interesting
song choice for the end credits because
it's like so
serene in a way
as opposed to the rest of the movie
character animations well done guys
wow
this is interesting to okay okay i see
i see how they're doing this earth a kit
eartha kit nice okay i should have
picked that out
dang
looking at these credits to it it kind
of makes me want to
go and look at you know
other animated movies
since this came out just to see how
they've changed or go look at older ones
like this is cool that they that at
least for a part of this what they're
doing is yeah crediting each character
and who worked on each character instead
of just going by you know here's the
voice cast and now here's just a bunch
of animators in one big block you know
clean up animation like it's funny
looking at these credits it's like you
can almost learn
about the process
look at how many different places they
sent these out to be cleaned up and
whatnot how many people worked on each
different character how many people did
like the in between frames it's pretty
cool
curious what the vis effects would have
been at this point in time
that's right sting this is for the
parents who want to chill before they
got that car ride home
david spade i should have caught him up
at the top but david spade of course
okay it's a good call too i thought he
was really good in this role like i was
never uh yeah like a big david spade fan
like i you know it depends you know
sometimes he pops up and stuff i like
sometimes he pops up and things where
i'm like
but i thought you did a great job here
it's a perfect choice cultural you know
background aside
god i wish they would make movies like
this again
i wish 2d animation wasn't dead
in this way i mean i know they did what
klaus for netflix which i still need to
check out i've heard the the animation
on that is really beautiful i do yeah i
miss hand-drawn animation
nothing after the credits
now this isn't from that time all right
that was a blast and a half let's talk
about it let's do it guys we did it at
long
long last
that was a whole whole lot of fun it's
it's you know it's been a long time
building up this movie i was you know
i've been aware of it since it came out
and i remember everybody around me
really being jazzed on it at the time
and then you know as time has gone on
it's not like the first movie anybody
brings up in conversation but i feel
like it's maintained a certain level of
you know love in the disney canon over
all these years since it dropped
originally and i can definitely see why
it's funny you know and i don't want to
blast theme here i very much enjoyed
tangled greg and i checked that out just
recently and that was another movie that
you know seemed to hail a change of pace
or or at least or a new kind of bar
setting for disney or you know a certain
direction
kind of forward into you know a new age
of filmmaking in the animated realm uh
and tangled was one that you know came
with
probably an equal amount of hype i mean
i feel like a lot of people in
conversation i can think of have pointed
to that movie of like nah that's like a
great you know recent disney music or
like that's one of the high water marks
and i enjoyed tangled most certainly um
but it was uh maybe a little over hyped
for me and i think greg might agree with
that too um you know like i said it was
very charming it was very fun but it did
feel kind of slight in a way and uh
didn't feel
quite akin to what i had been led to
expect whereas this
by contrast at least for me
was sort of everything people promised
me it would be like this was so much fun
and this had such a great energy and
even though it is a very sort of
straightforward story and it is a very
compact movie it's only like 70 minutes
or so 72 73 minutes uh it still felt
like just the right amount of time and i
don't know if that's me being
conditioned by recent you know
disney movies being you know in that
seat you know if you're changing
animation style perhaps that will lead
you to expect something different from
the experience and you know having even
more recent films in mind like a frozen
or whatever like that as i recall kind
of
goes more substantial in terms of how it
wants to subvert expectations with the
story and blah blah blah um
but this yeah like it felt like just the
right proportion for everything they
were trying to do and from what i
understand this was you know kind of
segued out of a much heavier bigger
project about the inc creation myth
right because this is the incan empire
which i don't know a ton about but i did
love the aesthetics of i love the way
they sort of realized that uh even
though you know you've got white david
spade playing a peruvian which wouldn't
happen now but i thought he was he was
terrific and i'll get to the voice cast
in a moment but um he
was such a wonderful lead in this i know
people probably talk a lot about the
supporting characters and i've never
been like the biggest david spade fan
but i i thought he
really well embodied the cartoon and the
attitude and
the journey of this character like i
bought all the notes of his performance
from you know obviously david's bait can
do the smug quipping
and things like that you know the
one-liners and the you know uh just the
rhinos this is a very rye-feeling movie
and uh there's a lot of you know sort of
absurd but also somewhat meta like you
know i can see definitely how this
hailed in sort of a new
um uh timbre for these kinds of disney
animated movies you know they're aiming
in a different direction with the comedy
it's a little more zany it's a little
more slapstick again it's a bit more rye
there are a few more things for the
parents in the crowd not tons it's not
going raunchy necessarily but yeah like
this for its time i can definitely see
sort of re-establishing what the
attitude is and what the humor style can
be moving forward not to say that all
the disney movies of this era are like
this but yeah this definitely feels like
one of those shifts whereas like you
know i think to recent times frozen felt
like one of those shifts but frozen is
going even more meta of like we're
taking our story tropes and we are
confronting them and directly subverting
them whereas this is more we're taking a
different approach and a different
attitude and i appreciate that and you
know it's not to compare this to frozen
because it's not really fair to do that
but yeah this felt like
there's something that's like less
self-aware to me about the way that
something like this plays versus a
frozen where it's like part of the
brownie points or you're like okay they
know that we know so they're doing
something different whereas this is just
it's a different attitude it's still a
disney movie at its core there's still a
really endearing journey of you know
this character having to
i mean you know in the in the princess
stories perhaps there isn't as much of
you know this sort of um this guy who's
like clearly a jerk who has to learn to
have a heart like you know aladdin's
like a street thief and whatever but
he's a great guy with a heart of gold
you know it's like there are things that
are different mainly with that rightness
of like you have this character who is
abrasive and who
you know is uh
you know very self-centered and is
funny but often at everybody else's
expense uh but yeah like having this new
tone having this you know sort of more
looney tunes-esque sort of style of
abandon and slapstick and silliness
applied to
you know the disney i often associate
with more sweeping earnest tones and so
yeah this definitely feels again like i
said a sort of tone shift for them but
in a way that yeah is like less
self-aware than something or there's
just i don't know it feels a little more
in earnest still because it is not quite
as far down the meta rabbit hole of you
know having fun like twisting and poking
and like see we know and we're changing
everything up um yeah it just feels like
it's a very natural change even though
from what i understand at least from the
behind the scenes that you know like
finally getting to this version of the
movie was a difficult process but when
you look at the final product you can't
really tell uh because yeah i mean the
animation is really beautiful i love the
way they uh drew the empire the way they
realized like the magic especially in
the sort of ending bits where you have
all these potions going off and
different creature transformations and
stuff like that and yizma's lab too
was super cool like like they almost
could have leaned more into that kind of
stuff for me because it's sort of
reminding me the way you know she's got
all these beakers and tubes and fluids
boiling and they're all sort of filtered
through this you know appropriately sort
of incan uh aesthetic you know art style
like it reminded me of some of the
trippier sequences you would see in some
of the other you know disney animated
films that do sort of indulge in the
impressionism and in the you know just
sort of uh decadence of design uh or two
like that moment where uh you know
cusco is on the ridge and there's that
morning fog that layer of just you know
dewy fog and you can see that shadow
being cast uh you know in relief of the
light like things like that like are
really choice i think and then getting
out of the empire and just into these
lush valleys and these environments
you know it really made me miss and it's
funny like pixar is often credited with
you know really igniting the boom of cg
animated you know films in this vein and
they have often said like it wasn't ever
our goal to kill 2d animation and going
back and looking at this i'm like man i
wish disney would make more 2d
hand-drawn films today because yeah just
the line work and the the art style
really feels like moving pieces of art
and that's really
just wonderful to behold and really
tangible like there's just something
different not to slight computer
animation whatsoever there's just
something different about it and there's
something that's like really warm and
rich especially when it's done well and
especially when all the elements are
coming together as well as they are here
between again the voices the animation
the humor the music and this i was
actually surprised and not in a bad way
it's not a gripe but i was expecting
this to be a much more music-centric
film i was expecting a a full-on musical
rather than something that has like a
bookend set of songs by tom jones which
i wasn't expecting at all
but it's always fun to see tom jones i
love that like of all the singers out
there like tom jones pops up in a lot of
movies and uh so yeah like i i enjoyed
the musical numbers that they did
include i feel like that's sort of
requisite for disney but yeah i was i
was sort of surprised surprised
pleasantly
uh that i like a good musical but yeah i
was like okay so this isn't so much of a
musical and it's not really about like
i mean you know the emperor has his
groove
but it's not about him being a dancer or
something like that you know like the
the
the title and just knowing it's a disney
movie sort of led me to this idea that
like oh it must be like about this guy
is finding yeah i don't know some kind
of dancer like losing his mobility to
dance and getting it back whatever and
not to say that music isn't like an
integral part of this movie because the
more i've thought about it and just
revisited some of the footage and stuff
like that like it does occur to me that
while it's not as overt it's more about
you know the music of life so to speak
you know harmonizing with others instead
of creating dissonance you know playing
with the people around you instead of
over them i think that you know cusco's
house couscotopia is a good metaphor for
that and the way to in which like yeah
he starts out doing this big old number
and he gets tripped up and then from
there kind of everything falls apart and
he ultimately has to yeah like regain
his groove and learn to march to a new
you know beat and yeah you know when
they are escaping back to town and
they're like racing uh kronk and isma
back you know they get that sort of like
really big band kind of jazzy musical
like there is a lot of music in here and
i think you know it's not being a
full-on musical makes some of that feel
a little less obvious and uh yeah i
think that's actually kind of a cool
thing about it uh because you know he
even talks about like you said the hills
sing and they don't sing you know as
he's you know playing up his giving uh
you know or is deciding not to demolish
pacha's home and all that stuff just
yeah like i appreciated uh the more and
more just the way music as a theme and
as just you know as a fan of music
myself and somebody who you know takes a
lot of musical ideas as you know
metaphors for life and whatnot i thought
this really nicely kind of embodied that
and drawn drew a nice sort of like
connection point to the character um so
yeah like like i do think the title and
the sort of music centrism suggested is
there it's just not in the way it's not
in the obvious way you would think and
also i mean shouts out to john debney
and and tom jones and sting and
everybody else who contributed music to
this because the the musical score and
the music underlying the action
throughout is very lively uh so yeah i i
was surprised by where it went but i was
also just like really really easily
swept up you get this i like the choice
of the narration by cusco and sort of
having you know like the irony come out
through that you know
that he's obviously an unreliable
narrator telling his story to be much
more you know flattering than it
actually is and meeting him yeah in this
state of misfortune and then going to
see how this all happened and watching
you know him and isma
you just bounce off each other and and
like that even again this the plot is
pretty straightforward you've got a
self-centered uh oblivious prince who
doesn't really regard anybody but
himself and you know he's making his
summer home on somebody else's
literal home
driving people out of where they live
completely ignoring or
seeing past any of the concerns or
legitimacies in his immediate staff and
whatnot he is yeah transformed thrust
out has to go through a journey of
growth and self-discovery and and
humbling only to come back and yeah
reclaim his position and and become the
benevolent ruler he was always meant to
be uh and then yeah you have uh the the
advisor who wants to take his role and
her you know dim-witted and not
dimwitted actually uh you know assistant
like cronk oh my god like isma and cronk
are really terrific and that's another
thing i thought was really great about
this movie was the four main
characters or the two main pairs if you
want to put it that way are so well
realized i mean i really enjoyed the
character designs as well as the ways in
which the voice actors complimented them
and yeah you have a really charming
straight man and funny guy dynamic
between you know sort of an odd couple
dynamic between uh pacha and cusco and
yeah like pache is so sweet and
thoughtful and he's got his family and
everything and yeah he's trying to kind
of help
cusco see the error of his ways and how
he could be better towards people and
how he could use his power to make
things better for everybody
uh and then yeah you've got cusco who's
obviously kuzco and then on the other
side of that equation and on the on the
other side of the you know protagonist
antagonist spectrum you have gizmo and
cronk who are yeah so funny to get like
they're both scene stealers and they
both work really well together like
eartha kitt and patrick warburton just
mwah like between her like she fully
like her voice and that's why i was
expecting like more music because you
know obviously eartha kitt is a singer
as well um and i would have loved to
have heard her pipes on this uh you know
not to slight tom jones and sting
uh but yeah like their performances
together combined with the animation of
those characters especially ismo with
yeah just this like crazy witchy but
also sort of like lounge singery you
know like slinky dress kind of quality
like i really enjoyed
the way that they realized that
character and yeah it was just a perfect
meld of voice actors with animation and
all the different bits uh especially
with cronk like cronk is perhaps like
the biggest scene stealer of them all
because yeah in some ways like he's he's
good natured and and a little naive so
and that can make him
come off dim-witted or serve the role of
a dim-witted character in certain
moments but he's also like hyper
competent and like a total renaissance
man which is yeah just hilarious when it
comes to like communicating with
squirrels and hearing patrick
warburton's voice just like squeak
squeak squeaking you know like his again
patrick warburton like you've heard his
voice everywhere by now and and you know
at this point in time in the current day
he's
and everywhere you know he's in so many
things and he's so many characters uh
and uh yeah here it was just like a tour
de force of his like quintessential
patrick warburton
you know but it perfectly applied and
yeah like watching him step into the
kitchen and and taking everybody's
orders as the cook and you're like oh
here it comes he's gonna get overwhelmed
oh no wait he's actually completely on
top of it uh things like that his whole
devil and angel bit too like again
that's like such a well-worn trope but
it was hilarious to hear his take on it
and to hear the way like it's you know
you've got his voice all pitch shifted
and everything
um but two just the way that those three
even interact and the way that that
motif grows by the end like is so
satisfying and and even the way like
they use
jokes and stuff like that to fill plot
like that whole thing about like how did
we get back here before you
and he pulls up the map and he's like
yeah
it literally makes no sense and uh you
know it's like things like that like
yeah they're they're literally just like
fixing a plot hole by calling out the
plot hole and it's partly due i think to
his perfect delivery of something like
that that really
you know makes you laugh with it instead
of going uh cheating you know uh so yeah
like the the way all of them uh sort of
interact with each other and the way the
story goes you know you know that cronk
ultimately probably will end up in some
better place that more serves his unique
talents as well as just his good nature
so that was really nice to see him like
training the next generation of scouts
and yeah you know cusco ultimately
deciding to make his summer home not on
top of pacha's home but on top of you
know an adjacent unoccupied space so
that they can be buddies and neighbors
like that's really heartwarming and yeah
like you know you kind of know a lot of
the places the plotting is gonna go but
i thought every place they went in order
to get there was pretty interesting and
yeah you get your time sort of
out in the out in the wilderness out in
the elements again that great thing
where he's like alone and surrounded by
the eyes and everything and yeah you
have your sort of
um
yeah you know in the elements chase as
they are you know sort of tracking uh
pacha and kuzco down and trying to
follow their trail and you know yeah
coming into close proximity like they
made a lot of really great bits and
really fun uh tension like comedic
tension out of having them both show up
at the little you know diner place
and then later on having them back at
the you know uh in back in the you know
the the
i don't want to call it a castle it's
not a castle the palace i'll say you
know they're back there and they have
that uh bit with the the last vial and i
thought that was something too that that
made for a both really funny slapstick
routine that just kept on going but
didn't get tedious in my opinion it kept
getting funnier the more it went but
also the more it drove up the tension
because you know that it is important
that they get this back and they don't
lose it it's the only one it's the only
one that can turn kuzco back to the way
he's supposed to be
and uh yeah like again it's a testament
to the animation and from what i
understand about the previous project
that this came out of that was going to
be a much heavier more serious musical
movie and so to see this go in the
complete opposite direction and do it so
successfully and to so successfully
embody
the bombast but also like it splits the
difference really nicely it's got the
bombast and the slapstick and the sight
gags and things like that of a more uh
sort of
um no it's not chuck jones not chuck
berry like a chuck jones or just like a
looney tunes kind of thing
but mixed with a certain amount of that
disney heart like you know that heart is
underneath and is going to be revealed
as the movie goes and i think yeah like
for the time this came out this is a
nice tweak
on the disney formula that yeah i can
see how like this even feels fresh to me
now uh because yeah even though there's
a different sense of humor that has
obviously been influenced by this and by
the rest of pop culture moving past this
this does feel like a more direct like
nah this is like a you know like a
snappy punchy comedy and i really really
appreciated that and again hats off to
david spade like again me not the
biggest david spade fan it sort of
depends on the project and this is
definitely a win project like i loved
what he did with pretty much everything
in this like i thought he really well
embodied the character and he made me
laugh a bunch of times with his uh
subtle and and
quirky deliveries and things like that
and that was really gratifying you know
along with the you know voice actors who
you know are gonna do a great job like
something like that i was like oh
interesting like that's fun i didn't
fully pick it out at first and i might
not have and that's always a nice
surprise so yeah i think that's uh those
are my thoughts at least for right now
you know me i could always go for
an hour on these things but it's you
know it's a disney movie it's the
emperor's new groove we don't need to be
here all day um so yeah leave me your
thoughts on this let me know what you
you know i mean i imagine a lot of you
probably saw this when it first came out
or saw this as part of your childhood so
just let me know what your experience
with the film is like what some of your
favorite moments are uh just yeah
anything and everything you want to
share i am happy to take in because
sharing is caring and uh yeah thanks for
joining me these have been really fun to
do these solo movie reactions i mean i
always love reacting to stuff with greg
and checking stuff out with greg but
yeah getting this opportunity to
you know fill in the gaps in my own
music viewing history or sorry movie
viewing history
uh you know is always appreciated it's
always a treat and uh yeah i hope you
all are doing well and i'll catch you
for the next one much love and as always
cheers
pandemic jones pandemic
i miss you buddy if there's any emperor
that i would follow around you know in a
cool you know uh what do you call that
map montage thing you know all
throughout the lands on your self-growth
journey it would be you pandemic i miss
you buddy you're a sweet guy already
though you you just ark into a sweeter
guy that would be your character arc for
this movie but yeah i hope you're doing
well and i miss you on the live streams
we got to get some more live streams
going so that we can hang once more but
dude always appreciate your support it
always brings me some joy puts a smile
on my face when i see your little
profile pic or when i see you leaving a
comment or when i see you pop up you
just make me feel good my friend so i
hope you're doing well and uh yeah we'll
catch you next month stay sexy
and uh hey
keep the groove on
gotta make a groove joke somehow i don't
know yeah you you love you but you get
it
[Music]